always good to see these winds calm down
and it is going to be a great last day
of march everybody
plant some door sometime outdoors today
i think you'll really enjoy it
just a slight breeze you can see that
sun is up this morning and shining
bright
as we head into our last day of march
cool 20s up there at kyle canyon
we've had some breezes north breezes up
around centennial hills
to floyd lamb thule springs in that area
otherwise most of the valleys pretty
quiet
upper 40s up there right at the strip
we're in the upper 40s 49
sunrise mountain right now and low 50s
green valley
seven hills at 48 45 for rhodes ranch
over to mountains edge this morning
strong gusty winds persistent winds
along the colorado river gusts have been
to 35 miles an hour
all night and early this morning in
laflin and that's where we'll keep the
winds perhaps at 41 mesquite as well
25 in cali any it's cold up there in
lincoln county
but we'll be a little warmer this
afternoon 74 degrees is perfectly normal
for the last day of march we're going to
hop right into your hot
weekend forecast in fact we'll probably
tie the record for saturday at 91.
yeah these are the right numbers i
promise 90 degrees on easter sunday
mostly sunny skies
it's all thanks to high pressure that
will continue to build stronger
over the next several days as we head
towards your weekend and
i mean 80 tomorrow upper 80s friday it's
not going to take long to get to those
90s
we're just going to zoom right to the
heat way ahead of normal
next week we get back to some more
normal 70s thank goodness nate